défi communiste communisants vérité
d'hommes semblables niveau
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous écoutez
scopeo l'observateur politique
je suis au mythique cofondatrice de
scopeo et je vous souhaite la bienvenue
sur ce neuvième épisode de notre série
il entrevit politique
aujourd'hui nous sommes très honorés de
recevoir monsieur nicolas fram
mais avant tout je laisse la parole à
emilien rédacteur chez scopeo pour
qu'ils puissent poser le décor de ce
nouveau podcast
merci domitille bonjour à celles et ceux
qui nous écoutent et surtout bonjour à
vous monsieur nicolas froidmont bonjour
vous nous fait le plaisir aujourd'hui de
nous accorder cette entrevue pour
discuter ensemble de sujets relatifs à
la stratification sociale est la lutte
des classes pour préparer cette entrevue
nous nous sommes appuyés sur votre
dernier livre qui s'intitule la guerre
des mots combattre le discours politico
médiatique de la bourgeoisie et vous
avez co écrit avec céline derkaoui mais
avant de démarrer l'entrevue monsieur
framont je vous laisse vous présenter
brièvement pour ceux qui nous écoutent
oui très bien merci de m'avoir invité
donc nicolas ramond alors je me présente
comme sociologue et puis surtout comme
co rédacteur en chef d'un magazine en
ligne qui s'appelle frustration qui est
un magazine qui existe depuis 2013 qui a
d'abord été un magazine papier puis
qu'est devenu un magazine entièrement
web
il y à peu près trois ans donc ça c'est
une de mes activités
sinon bon j'ai exercé différentes
professions liées à la sociologie j'ai
enseigné à l'université à paris iv
sorbonne pendant plusieurs années puis
j'ai travaillé à l'assemblée nationale
puis j'ai travaillé comme expert pour
les représentants du personnel dans les
entreprises
et puis actuellement là je suis en cours
de reconversion pour être j'ai rejoint
l'exploitation de mon compagnon qui donc
agriculteurs agriculture biologique en
reprise de l'exploitation de mes parents
donc en fait je vais faire ça c'est à
dire à la fois d'y aller j'ai un
magazine en ligne
et puis en même temps faire une activité
agricole ce qu'ils ont fait convient
parfaitement
voilà pour les grandes lignes alors
merci on va on va aborder en premier
lieu une question que vous abordez dans
votre livre qui est la question de la
classe moyenne
c'est un terme qui est assez omniprésent
dans la bouche des hommes politiques
puisque en utilisant ce terme
dans l'impression de s'adresser à la
majorité des français mais c'est une
notion qui demeure assez flou et qui
n'est jamais très clairement définis
donc premièrement comment est-ce que
vous la définiriez et pour en rapport
avec la classe moyenne a également un
programme de sms de lycée on habitué à
avoir ce schéma de la toupie pour
présenter la stratification sociale avec
en bas des classes des classes sociales
pauvres qui sont relativement faibles et
des classes sociales riches qui sont
relativement peu nombreuses et également
mais une très large majorité de deux
classes moyennes donc est-ce que ce
schéma de la toupie qui était valable
après les trente glorieuses est encore
d'actualité
ou est ce que la classe sociale la
classe moyenne est en train de
disparaître
c'est très intéressant que vous parliez
de ce schéma de la toupie puisque
moi-même j'en ai un bon souvenir pour
l'avoir eu moi même dans mes propres
pour des c s et c'est très intéressant
parce que je pense c'est bah c'est un
schéma qui marque marc les imaginaires
et c'est un schéma qui qui est à la fois
idéologique je vais revenir là dessus et
donc je vais commencer par vous parler
du schéma et ensuite éventuellement
s'arrêtera sur cet épineux problème de
la définition
donc je pense qu'il faut revenir un peu
dans l'histoire sociologique de cette
classe moyenne
originellement on a tendance à
stratifier la société sous régime
capitaliste en deux catégories qui sont
principalement ceux qui possèdent et
ceux qui travaillent
ça c'est ce qu'on nous présente souvent
comme la mélisse classique un petit peu
datés c'est ça du xixème siècle celle
qui a été réalisé en grande partie par
marx mais pas uniquement
ce schéma dont qui prédomine dans
l'analyse de la société
jusque dans les années 80 en réalité
c'est la structure même le discours
politiques tous bords confondus
mais évidemment hors ekis ce schéma là
bas il est basé sur une idée qui aurait
finalement un antagonisme entre
différentes classes sociales tourner
autour du travail principalement ce
schéma il a été très contestée
évidemment puisque bas c'est une grille
de lecture du monde 1 faut toujours
penser qu' on a différentes grilles de
lecture elles représentent elles
correspondent à des vérités sociologique
est pour moi l 100 elle s'en rapproche
ou pas mais c'est avant tout des grilles
de lecture qu'elles sont toujours
questionnable etc c'est toujours
important de questionner ses grilles de
lecture là mais ce qui est intéressant
de voir c'est que à partir des années 80
s'est imposé en lieu et place de cette
grille de lecture exploiteurs et
exploités ou à si vous voulez possédant
travailleurs une autre grille de lecture
qui est celle symbolisée par la toupie
de denrées demandera donc effet un
sociologue qui en fait à la fin des
années 70 a théorisé l'idée selon
laquelle on allait sortir
progressivement d'une société qui
cassent à ce qu' il y aurait de plus en
plus célèbres aux classes moyennes qui
allait se se caractériser et ce qui est
important c'est de considérer que ce
schéma il a été fait par anticipation en
réalité henri mendras ceux d'eads a
prospective sur la base de la société
française des années 70 ce qui était
effectivement une société où la
répartition entre capital et travail
avait été fait par toute une série de
grandes réformes qu'on connaît celle de
l'après guerre mais ausis avec toutes
celles qui ont suivi c'est à dire à
queue après la libération
on a assisté à un formidable
redéploiement de richesse pour le coup
entre ceux qui possèdent et ceux qui
travaillent et donc effectivement on a
été sur une heure si vous voulez une
courbe de répartition des richesses qui
a fait qu'on on a pu croire à un moment
donné qu'on allait arriver vers
l'émergence d'une grande classe moyenne
mais en réalité c'est pas ce qui s'est
produit
ça qui est intéressant quand on regarde
la structure des inégalités en france
c'est que les inégalités baisse durant
les années 60 70 80 par le biais de
politiques de redistribution qu'on
connaît bien ce sera ce que la sécurité
sociale c'est une très grosse politique
de redistribution que toute une partie
des revenus qui était autrefois alloués
aux capitales ont été alloués à un
système d'économie socialiser qui est la
sécurité sociale donc évidemment il ya
eu toutes ces réformes là donc on
pouvait s'imaginer que les choses
allaient en fait s'équilibre et réalité
sais pas ce qui s'est produit et c'est
pour ça que cette toupie avec fosse en
réalité c'est qu'à partir du début des
années 90 les inégalités augmentent à
nouveau
elle augmente et pièces augmente de
façon exponentielle à l'orée des années
2000 est particulièrement après la crise
financière de 2008 et les différentes
crises qui ont ponctué l'histoire du
capitalisme depuis donc étaient des
crises qui ont redistribué les richesses
du bas vers le haut et même la crise
couvait actuelle la crise sanitaire
c'est une crise dans lequel je pense ou
ce dont on aperçoit on s'aperçoit sur
les données statistiques domine pas
c'est que les personnes qui étaient déjà
riches sont encore plus riches et les
personnes qui étaient déjà pauvres sont
encore plus beau donc en fait la toupie
elle marche pas du tout si on regarde la
société française ça fonctionne pas en
toupie j'irai plus pour moi que ça
fonctionne en pyramide si on devait
visualiser les choses
on est dans une société pyramidale avec
effectivement une minorité de riches
mais qui s'enrichissent une une portion
intermédiaire que nous dans nos tirs on
appelle la soupe bourgeoisie même si on
n'est pas tout à fait ce terme je pense
qu'on pourrait trouver mieux mais disons
l'idée c'est que vous avez la
bourgeoisie qui est le groupe de ceux
qui possèdent le capital et qui
monopolisent les richesses est
tendanciellement de plus en plus et puis
vous avez ce groupe intermédiaire que
nous on définit autour des 10% les plus
riches entre les 1% les 10% les plus
riches qui vont être le groupe
d'encadrement du système c'est-à-dire
les gens qui promeuvent le système
capitaliste en retire un certain nombre
de fruits même si ce sont pas les plus
riches en bénéficient et c est le revenu
de 10 % les plus riches a d'ailleurs
augmenté aussi en 2020 et puis ensuite
bas vous avez tendanciellement les 90%
restants qui bien sûr sont répartis
entre différentes strates de revenus
mais qui pour moi ont plus de points
communs que de différences et ce point
commun est celui qu'on avait beaucoup
oublié avec la notion classes moyennes
c'est le fait qu'ils sont à des postes
plus ou moins subordonnés c'est pas
simplement
alors ça peut être même même quand on a
fait des niveaux d'études
on a un certain niveau d'études on peut
avoir un poste subordonnés et se postent
subordonnés autres au service des autres
en fait nous empêche d'accumuler du
capital et pour moi c'est bien ça la
grosse différence structurelle dans la
société c'est est ce qu'il ya des gens
qui accumule du capital et ce capital
lors de ne pouvoir sur le reste de la
société
et puis à côté de ça il ya des gens qui
simplement donc leur force de travail
c'est ce que disait marx mais sa reste
vrais pour la grande majorité d'entre
nous et du coup on accumule rien dans
leurs vignes au fur et à mesure des
générations et donc se retrouve tout le
temps en position a dominé et du coup
pour revenir une fois qu'on a fait cette
petite généalogie du concept
il faut bien voir voilà comme je vous
dis tout ça c'est des grilles de lecture
concurrentes
il faut bien voir que la grille de
lecture lutte des classes elle sert un
certain temps
des politiques notamment le renversement
des cas social des idées politiques
on vous dirait de gauche mais moi je
dirais surtout voilier à la lutte des
classes anticapitaliste et cette grille
de lecture qui a consisté à dire non
mais tout va bien regarder il va y avoir
une très grosse classe moyenne dans
lequel on va tous être quelques riches
parce qu'il en faut bien quelques
pauvres parce qu'il en faut bien passer
une grille de lecture qui elle sert
plutôt l'ordre établi parce que
finalement la société devient acceptable
à partir du moment où on dit boom à la
richesse et la pauvreté c'est des choses
relativement marginal et pour la
majorité d'entre nous qui nous attend
les dettes rien bon la société
acceptable si vous commencez à dire non
il ya des dominants il ya des dominés et
se perpétue à travers le temps sans
critère de justice là ça devient
inacceptable dont il ya bien un combat
politique danser dans ses grilles de
lecture là même si évidemment au moins
la grille de lecture lutte des classes
est bien plus proche de la réalité
sociale tu la grille de lecture moyenne
histoire dira classes moyennes et du
coup bas la conséquence de tout ça quand
vous demandez de définir la classe
moyenne c'est que bart du coup moi je
pense que c'est un concept relativement
floue et que si on voulait tout à fait
correct un mythe moi je veux bien qu'il
y ait une classe moyenne même si je sais
pas s'ils emploient le terme de classes
mais pour les gens moyen en france ce
serait les gens qui se situerait autour
du salaire médian
c'est là médian a donc c'est pour ça que
c'est important d'ailleurs de prendre la
médiane que la moyenne médian c'est 50%
au moins 50% en plus là vous êtes au
milieu et vous pouvez vous dire moyens
et dans ces cas là tendanciellement les
gens qui sont moyens en france
sexuellement c'est des gens qui gagnent
tout vaut mieux confondues à peu près
2000 euros par mois là où qu'exceller
personne moyenne mais on voit bien dans
le discours politique que en élite et
quand il parle de classes moyennes les
différends politiques de tout bord
confondu
en fait qui parle pas simplement de ces
gens qui gagnent autour de 2 millions
souvent ils vont parler d'ailleurs on
parle souvent de classes moyennes
supérieures et là on parle de gens qui
peuvent gagner jusqu'à 5000 euros par
mois donc on voit bien qu'il ya un gros
souci là dessus et que cette définition
selon moi ce terme est largement
inopérant en fait on ferait mieux de
s'en passer
pour mieux comprendre la réalité sociale
que de continuer à l'utiliser pour ne
pas la décrire voilà je me permets juste
de répondre encore sur la toupie et de
la société pyramidale que vous savez que
vous avez décrite
en décrivant la société pyramidale où
semble être plus ou moins peut-être en
accord avec les la tête d'emmanuel todd
avec une élite qui est relativement peu
nombreuses et une masse atomisé qui est
très nombreuses qu'est ce que vous
pensez au contraire du modèle qui serait
plus un modèle de sablier qui
correspondrait plus à la france 2
décrite par christophe guilluy avec une
france d'en haut une france d'en bas et
une classe moyenne qui serait très très
peu nombreuses je pense qu'effectivement
en face que comme je dis ce qu'on entend
par classe moyenne en réalité elle est
allée peu nombreuses
la majorité des gens au travail gagnent
moins de 2500 euros et c'est donc le
groupe qu'on appelle souvent classes
populaires une avec classe laborieuse
c'est à dire ceux qui voient là où un
salaire et sont limités dans leur
pouvoir d'achat est très majoritaire
mais du coup pour moi ça va plus dans le
sens d'un schéma pyramidal parce
qu'encore une fois les plus riches sont
peu nombreux encore une fois pour moi si
on cumule voilà ce qu'ils possèdent
vraiment notre économie au point d'en
tirer de pouvoir la contrôler on parle
de voilà de 1 5% de la population a
c'est à dire à ceux qui dirigent notre
économie ce qui dirige notre politique
si vous voulez si on - la définition de
ce qu'est la bourgeoisie c'est pas
simplement le patronat mais c'est aussi
les très hauts fonctionnaires les
membres de la classe politique y seront
produites à le temps les gens qui ont
une aura médiatique et culturel voilà
c'est des gens qui sera en position
direction et qui par ailleurs tirs des
gros revenus de ça c'est au revenu qui
leur permette d'avoir ces postes de
direction mais cesser ces postes de
direction qui leur permet d'avoir ce
rôle
ces deux dimensions à prendre en compte
donc je sais pas si je parlerai de
sablier voilà parce qu'encore une fois
quantitativement
moi je trouve que le schéma pyramidal
fonctionne pas mal si on veut visualiser
les choses c'est à dire en réalité on a
une base large une base large fait de
gens qui tendanciellement mêmes modes de
vie ont les mêmes galères financières
c'est un peu la base vie et j'ose vous
pouvez dire c'est des gens qui voient là
avaient pour point commun d'avoir du mal
à boucler leur comme moi évidemment il
ya des gens encore bien plus pauvre que
ça faut pas l'oublier quand on gagne le
rsa dont les difficultés qui sont
autrement plus considérable et puis
ensuite petit à
tiba le nombre d'élus se raréfient à
travers monde dans la société et je
dirais eux si je devais rapport aux
théories vous venez c'est intéressant
parce que clairement quelqu'un comme
christophe guilluy ou emmanuel todd
c'est des gens qui pour moi un immense
mérite de proposer des grilles de
lecture de la réalité sociale basée sur
des faits donc après ça peut être des
théories concurrentes et vous peut
toujours discuter par exemple pour moi
qui te le dis mais c'est quelqu'un qui
met beaucoup trop l'accent sur les
paramètres géographique situé sur les
paramètres sociaux et sur le travail
mais bon pour moi c'est quand même des
théories qu'on ne mérite de ramener la
question sociale et des inégalités
sociales et de les expliquer ça c'est
très important
vous avez mentionné la la la question
des idées jeunes rapidement et la vision
qu'on avait de la dissolution de la
société et donc d'éclater prisé dans la
société
les énormes et aux manifestations du
village auront été très médiatisée et
souvent la classe médiatique qui était
plutôt ordinairement classé à la gauche
a une une approche d'aidé gilet jaune
qui pouvait parfois considéré comme
plutôt plutôt bourgeoise par rapport aux
débordements notamment non violence
qu'il ya pu avoir
est ce que vous considérez que cette
gauche est devenue trop bourgeoise pour
que pour se préoccuper des
revendications du peuple par oui ou pour
répond pas ou par oui et je vais
développer je pense oui que c'est le
gros problème de notre temps
ce qu'on essaie d'expliquer dans le
livre c'est que le clivage gauche droite
qu'il est vu comme quelque chose de très
structurant dans la société française
n'a pas toujours été en réalité quand on
regarde l'histoire du mouvement envoyé
par exemple dans lequel moi je pense le
mouvement des jeunes est une sorte
d'étape même s'ils s'en revendiquent pas
explicitement mais disons le mouvement
ouvrier pris au sens large c'est-à-dire
le monde des travailleuses et des
travailleurs au améliorer leurs
conditions de vie pour remettre en
question la société
ne sait pas toujours identifiés à la
gauche à la gauche la droite et la
gauche c'est un peu les offres
politiques institutionnelles existantes
et puis il se trouve que par moments par
contre les intérêts on va dire le combat
ouvrier des travailleurs des personnes
on peut dire du bas peuple aussi parce
que ça ça fonctionne un des personnes
subordonnés a coïncidé et s'est
identifié fortement à la gauche à une
certaine époque
donc évidemment l'âge d'or de ceux de
cette identification si les années 50 60
70 c'est à dire quand pour le coup la
raison d'être d'un certain nombre de
partis politiques comme le parti
communiste comme le parti socialiste
était de représenter une classe sociale
ça a été le cas pendant un temps mais
ceux auxquels on a assisté dans les
années 80 c'est qu'il ya une rupture
assumée de la part de ces organisations
politiques entre leurs représentations
de classe et leur action politique et
cette rupture etc s'est beaucoup appuyé
d'ailleurs comme je vous disais sur ses
grilles de lecture un peu erronée selon
moi deux classes moyennes c'est de dire
bon il ya plus d'une des classes en
france voilà tout ça c'est terminé
ça a été un peu décrété dans les années
80 et donc nous avant tout on va
construire de nouveaux clivages et ça
vous avez des a été quelque chose de
plus ou moins assumée de la part de
toutes ces organisations le parti
communiste dans les années 90 s'est mis
à avoir une orientation qui se disait
plus humaniste plus humanitaire c'est à
dire que voilà on est plus les
travailleurs qui luttent on aide les
pauvres et les nécessiteux donc voilà on
est passé d'un discours offensif un
discours un peu charitable ça c'est vrai
pour le parti communiste le parti
socialiste on c'est une histoire plus
complexe en même temps plus connu c'est
que le parti socialiste historiquement a
toujours aidé composé plus de deux
membres de la bourgeoisie ou de la soul
bourgeois dit qu'il y avait à coeur de
défendre les intérêts du peuple mais qui
sitôt arrivé au pouvoir ou une tendance
plutôt à être solidaires
de la classe bourgeoise plus que le tas
ce populaire ça s'est vérifié
ça s'est vérifié dans les années 80 et à
cet égard le règne de françois
mitterrand tous très envie bus à la fois
des grandes réformes sociales les deux
premières années de son mandat et ce
fameux tournant de la rigueur des 83 qui
est quelque chose c'est une étape
historique
c'est cette façon tout d'un coup les
défenseurs de la classe laborieuse
laisse tomber ce qu'on va là en disant
de toute façon maintenant il ya des
impératifs qui font on n'a plus le choix
il ya le droit il ya la modélisation et
donc il ya eu 7 se lâcher le guide est
donc forcément basse ce qui s'est passé
et le phénomène n'a fait que se
confirmer dans les décennies qui ont
suivi c'est que alors que la classe
bourgeoise selon moi aixoise est très
représenté politiquement elle a des
partis qui la représente dont les
membres sont issus de ces classes là qui
ne peut-il pas qu'ils ont ces codes qui
ont qui pense comme elle a par contre la
classe laborieuse dans ses différentes
dimensions sont trouvés non représentés
politiquement
donc ça s'est accompagnée c'est ce qui
explique selon moi une grosse partie du
phénomène de l'abstention sur lequel
j'ai pu travailler par le passé
l'abstention électorale voilà c'est pas
simplement même pas du tout une question
de flemme d'individualisme c'est
simplement la déconnexion croissante
entre les institutions politiques et des
partis politiques et la population
ils et elles sont censées représenter
donc cette rupture se produit l'absence
d'augmentation augmente et
épisodiquement des grands événements
sociaux montre l'envi de politique et de
représentation politique et d'action
politique de la classe laborieuse dans
toutes ses dimensions et les gilets
jaunes sont un de ces exemples c'est à
dire de gens qui ne s'identifie aucune
organisation politique y compris celles
avec celle avec laquelle il avait des
revendications communes je pense à la
france un suisse parce que quand on voit
des revendications des gilets jaunes ses
proches de la france est soumise
mais ce qui est un peu remarquable c'est
pour autant quand bien même les
revendications sont les mêmes
on est vraiment dans un projet global
dans un rejet global de tout ce qui
ressemble de près ou de loin à un parti
politique
donc c'est ça le montant de gilet jaune
et ça doit nous pousser à considérer qu'
il ya un
froid qui n'a pas été comblé puisque
malheureusement oui
malheureusement le mouvement des gilet
jaune ça a été un moment fort mais qui
pour moi a pas permis de structurer non
plus une offre alternative en abordant
la question des gilets jaunes et est
depuis le début de cette entrevue d du
rapport entre la classe bourgeoise et et
du petit peuple on on va en arriver à
parler de des questions d'inégalité la
france est quand même le demeure un pays
très égalitaire puisque avec une forte
redistribution puisque cette
redistribution permet de diviser par
deux les cartes de niveau de vie entre
les 20 % les plus pauvres et les 20% les
plus riches
mais pour autant il ya en france une à
une certaine fascination pour les pour
les écarts de richesse comment est ce
que vous pouvez expliquer de ça est ce
que ce serait une jalousie vis-à-vis de
la réussite des plus riches est ce que
ce serait tout simplement une question
taboue du rapport à l'argent ou de l'une
des riches
alors bon je pense qu'aucune de ces
trois solutions
c'est quand même très important ce que
vous avez dit oui c'est vrai qu'en
france
encore maintenant et malgré beaucoup de
régression législatives dans la matière
on a encore un système qui est beaucoup
plus redistributif que dans d'autres
pays
et ce qui pour moi nourrit le fait que
nourrit et provient du fait que en
france on a une exigence égalitaire
forte
alors après à quoi l'attribuer aux
combats passés à la conscience politique
des gens mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est quand vous regardez les sondages
parce que sur la sécurité ou que ce soit
mais il ya beaucoup de sondages sur les
questions économiques les français sont
pourrait dire très à gauche c'est à dire
qu'en fait ils sont pas du tout pour les
privatisations ils sont pour une
économie
en partie nationalisée ils sont pour un
état qui intervient dans la distribution
des richesses donc ça c'est vrai à quoi
c'est dû
ben moi je dirais que donc dans cette
culture politique qui exige l'égalité et
ni par haine ni par jalousie des
chansons va la réussite mais simplement
parce que si vous voulez quand on a une
forte exigence de justice
il est difficile de tolérer les
inégalités parce que si vous voulez ce
qui va se passer c'est que et on fait
tout ça c'est quand tu quand vous
assistez à une inégalité
la première question que vous posez
c'est est-ce qu'elle est fondée en
raison ou pas à dire est ce que l est
nécessaire c'est une élite est
nécessaire pour que les choses
fonctionnent
est ce que l est justifié s'il ya des
critères de justice qui font que
certains en plus et d'autres moins est
ce qu'on pourrait faire autrement c'est
la troisième question alors pas sur les
deux premières questions
particulièrement quand on fait de la
sociologie c'est quand même très
compliqué de considérer que les
inégalités de revenus sont sont
justifiées puisque en fait pas dans la
plupart des cas déjà elles proviennent
l'héritage des héritages plus ou moins
directe pas simplement d'héritage ou
touchant ses parents décèdent
je parle du fait qu en france les plus
riches vont dans les meilleures écoles
que par ailleurs la dépense publique
c'est pour ça que quand on dit de la
france a un système égalitaire
oui et non parce que par ailleurs sur
l'éducation par exemple ce convoi
statistiquement un c'est que en france
je contribuables dépensent plus pour un
enfant issu de la bourgeoisie ou des 10%
les plus riches que pour un enfant de
pauvre on met plus d'argent dans les
écoles qui forment les ceux qui sont
déjà favorisés que pour les autres donc
là on a eu l'exemple de quelque chose
qui est inégalitaire de façon flagrante
donc si vous voulez quand on cherche les
origines des d'inégalités notamment de
richesse c'est difficile de trouver des
déclics art de justice
ça arrive bien sûr et ça va être très
mise en avant il ya une vraie narration
là dessus quand quelqu'un quand vous
avez le portrait d'un c'est toujours
intéressant mais du coup les portes et
de chefs d'entreprises dans des journaux
le journaliste va toujours mettre
l'accent sur ses caractéristiques
propres
c'est quelqu'un qui ait l'audace est
quelqu'un qui a su se dépasser c'est
quelqu'un qui a su prendre des risques
ça c'est une certaine vision des choses
quand vous creusez un peu avec bourreau
fait le parcours sociologique il ya très
peu de hasard
très peu de hasard non c'est quelque
chose qu'on fait parfait avec
frustration on fait des biographies et
on essaie de regarder ceux qui nous
dirigent
quelle a été leur parcours quand on
regarde un exemple le très français
c'est la famille mulliez
la famille mulliez qui possède notamment
le groupe auchan et puis en fait une
grande partie de nos enseignes de
distribution la famille mulliez il n'y a
pas de hasard si vous voulez c'est un
groupe d'actionnaires familiaux dont
vous faites partie si vous vous mariez
avec un ou une mulliez si vous êtes un
enfant de mulliez et dans ces cas là
c'est très simple on vous donne et c'est
dans la famille mulliez évidemment vous
avez un niveau de revenu c'est quand
vous avez sans doute une bonne éducation
mais en plus il ya de fortes chances que
à 25 30 ans on vous confie la direction
d'une des enseignes du groupe public
donc c'est difficile du coup si vous
voulez selon des critères de justice et
de mérite par exemple le mérite est une
valeur qui souvent invoqué dans ces
moments là assez difficile de trouver du
mérite là dedans récemment dans la
presse je voyais que alexandre milliers
donc le petit fils du patriarche de la
famille mulliez on va par exemple il est
devenu vice président d'auchan
je doute si vous voulez que ce soit
uniquement grâce à son mérite à ses
compétences sans dire que c'est
quelqu'un qui a volé tout ce qu'il a eu
c'est pas la question est simplement il
n'y a rien qui vient étayer le fait que
les particulièrement mériter sa place
donc voilà c'est toujours la question
qu'il faut se poser un système
inégalitaire
il doit pour être acceptée est fondée en
justice et il se trouve qu'en france il
n'est pas vraiment il n'est pas vraiment
alors on essaie si vous voulez même même
quand vous regardez chandhok très vite
politique ou administratif par exemple
on va dire oui mais bon il ya des
concours à la maison il ya des gens ils
réussissent des concours et d'autres
qu'il échoue des concours c'est vrai
sauf que bah pareil quand vous faites la
sociologie de ceux qui réussissent et
concours bas il se trouve que c'est
beaucoup ce dont les parents eux-mêmes
réussi des compos c'est très compliqué
si vous voulez de mettre un mais les
individus là dedans
même si
c'est très bien vue d'y croire et tout
le monde va dire et c'est normal quand
vous accédez à une position vous avez
toujours envie de dire aux autres et de
vous dire à vous même que vous l'avez
mérité mais à l'échelle de la société
soutient pas trop donc voila moi ma
réponse c'est que les inégalités sont
mal accepté parce que elles sont peu
justifié et je pense que alors pourquoi
particulièrement en france
eh bien écoutez moi j'ai tendance à
penser qu'en france on a un esprit
critique développée alors à quoi c'est
dû à notre histoire aux combats passés
et souvent on oppose à l'exemple america
américain où il ya beaucoup plus de
fictions justificatrice des inégalités
le fameux raid américain
et ça c est apparemment c'est vrai moi
je suis allé qu'une fois aux états unis
mais c'est vrai que ces discours que
vous pouvez entendre comme ça quand vous
discutez avec quelqu'un c'est à dire il
ya ceux qui réussissent et qui sont des
gens bien alors ça c'est fou qui a une
connotation morale derrière briques qui
m'avait dit ça quand on réussit aux
états unis s'est conclue ce sont des
gouttes personnes ça m'avait frappé
puisque je vous ai goût de personnes
c'est pas simplement quelqu'un qui
réussit c'est quelqu'un qui est plein de
bien donc en plus c'est ya une
connotation morale quoi donc se soudent
ça si longtemps quand même que ceux qui
réussissent pas céder mauvaise personne
donc je pense que ça va très loin ses
liens fond religieux qui lui au
protestantisme
j'aurai beaucoup d'explications là
dessus mais alors même que la société
américaine est tellement inégalitaire
par rapport à la nôtre que pour le coup
aux états unis on est uniquement dans la
reproduction sociale contrairement à ce
qu'on imagine les états unis pays
d'initiatives et c'est garder la
structure des inégalités et la
reproduction sociale aux états unis très
flotte parce que pour le coup aux états
unis vous n'avez aucune chance vire à
l'éducation est en payante dès le lycée
les soins et en payant à partir de là si
vous voulez vraiment oui il faut
vraiment des forces exceptionnelle et
une série de chance pour pouvoir passer
d'un milieu très populaire un milieu
très riche mais les américains en ce
sens de la narration la classe dominante
américaine sait parfaitement mettre en
scène la réussite de ses membres j'ai
toujours un exemple qui me revient parce
que sur deux on entend beaucoup on nous
sort toujours la légende de
moyer bill gates le fondateur de
microsoft qui a commencé dans son garage
ça c'est vraiment l'image d'épinal et
vous faites quoi vous gardez la
biographie de berguette c'est quelqu'un
dont la mère était à la présidence d'un
fonds d'investissement qui
investissaient dans les sociétés
informatiques dont le père était
professeur d'université et donc du coût
certain moment donné il ya eu sans doute
une bonne idée et contrairement à plein
d'autres gens lui ai eu les moyens de la
mettre en pratique
voilà donc je sais pas si ça répond à
votre question mais voilà l'inégalité
inégalités nous fait violences parce que
elle nous fait nécessairement parce qu'a
priori quand on pose le principe de
l'égalité humaine
les hommes naissent libres et égaux en
droit je pense que c'est quelque chose
qui nous imprègne tous
eh bien on est prêt à accepter l inverse
uniquement s'il ya de bonnes raisons
pour ça et tu es sous le capitalisme
c'est surtout des mauvaises raisons
en tout cas c'est des raisons qui sont
là qui sont pas de l'ordre de la justice
qui sont de l'ordre d'autres choses
alors après on peut dire et ça je pense
que beaucoup de gens pensent en france
on peut pas faire autrement on peut pas
faire autrement parce qu'on n'a pas de
système mais ça je comprends mais mais
peu de gens vous direz c'est
parfaitement juste voulais que les
enfants de miel et tu perds en formule y
ait récupéré les directions des boîtes
du bouclier bomba difficile un de
fondeyre horizons il avait fait un
parallèle avec donc puni des raclées les
états unis une question à très
intéressante et en effet selon les
sondages
aux etats unis la pauvreté et tend à
considérer comme un échec personnel
puisque 60% de la population pense que
les pauvres sont pauvres parce qu'ils
sont paresseux 29% parce qu'ils sont
enfermés dans un piège de pauvreté alors
qu'en europe les bourses et stages
totalement différent et surtout en
france où on a une certaine passion de
l'égalité le seul pays dans ligne
inscrire l'égalité dans notre devise a
eu ni la liberté par exemple beaucoup
plus fréquentes
donc c'est une question qui est
intéressante puisque qu'on fait des
sondages aux états unis
les américains considèrent davantage que
leur pays est égalitaire que les
français donc les américains ont
beaucoup plus haute estime que de
l'égalité dans la reprise que les
français alors que dans les faits on a
évidemment un système de redistribution
beaucoup plus développée et efficace en
france mais ce contraste interpelle sur
l'efficacité de la france de notre
recherche d'égalité puisque la meilleure
manière de réduire alors non pas les
égalités mais le sentiment de vide une
égalité et le sentiment d'injustice est
ce que ce serait pas du coup d'inciter à
l'effort eu la prise de risque plutôt
que de reverser directement de l'argent
aux personnes défavorisées
bah écoutez c'est ce qui est déjà en de
plus en plus en vigueur en france un la
majorité des réformes de notre système
de protection sociale si des dernières
années sont allées dans ce sens là avec
ce pari selon laquelle pour stimuler la
recherche de réussite il faut
conditionner par exemple des allocations
étudiants redistribution à l'épreuve
d'effort
par exemple l'idée que les personnes au
rsa dans votre cri travailler alors moi
je suis très critique de ça si ces
dispositifs existent c'est notamment
pour faire accepter un marché du travail
à accepter des faibles rémunérations
c'est pour tirer aussi des salaires par
le bas avec cette idée que voilà il faut
travailler quoi qu'il arrive quoi qu'il
en coûte
moi je suis pas d'accord avec ça je
pense que d'ailleurs les effets sont
relativement mauvais je pense qu'il faut
pas travailler
quoi qu'il en coûte je pense que le
travail à un prix là la dignité du
travail aussi qu'il ya des travaux qui
sont inutiles qui sont humiliant donc ça
sert à rien de pousser les gens à
travailler à tout prix c'est même une
façon de dévaloriser travail ces gens
parlent beaucoup de la valeur travail
mais moi je tiens la valeur travail et à
leur travail c'est de faire un travail
de qualité dans de bonnes conditions est
pour quelque chose d'utile et de plus en
plus on crée d'aider des pseudos travaux
moi je vois c'est simple 8 sur la peine
dans une agence pôle emploi par exemple
concret des services civiques qui a été
une façon de faire travailler la
jeunesse à tout prix vont en donnant
quelques revenus mais un positionnement
un travail plus intéressant
vous avez vous allez à pôle emploi il ya
des services civiques parce que des gens
voilà qui sont pas formés
pour ça qu'ils sont à l'accueil qu'ils
attendent à qui on confie des micros
tâche qui souvent sont là pour remplacer
des fonctionnaires comparaître et des
agents ont pas été remplacé ah oui je
pense que ça a contribué à dévaloriser
travail
et puis ensuite bon faut être très clair
par exemple quand on pense aux au
chômage sur le chômage
peu à peu près toutes les initiatives
législatives en la matière c'est une des
meilleures années sont allés dans le
sens et de dire pour réduire le chômage
il faut que les chômeurs trouvent du
travail
et s'il n'en trouve pas c'est parce
qu'ils ne veulent pas donc et tout un
tas de réformes pour inciter au contrôle
des chômeurs faire en sorte que vischer
du chômage etc
et là vous voyez ça tient pas à l'examen
des faits je veux j'ai pu le chiffre
exact en tête mais il faut voir que en
france on ait une pénurie d'emplois et
bien sûr qu'on trouvera toujours des
exceptions et toujours un secteur qui
n'arrivent pas à recruter et donc la
fausse opposition pourquoi d'ailleurs
mais si vous voulez certes il existe des
emplois non pourvus mais ça représente
qu'une infime minorité du nombre de
chômeurs donc ça sert à rien si vous
voulez de pousser tout le monde à
s'agiter en tous sens et de flics et de
menacer à la couture d'allocations si on
n'est pas capable de dégager des emplois
voyez la logique elle fonctionne pas et
vous aurez beau pousser tout le monde à
se dépasser à faire le meilleur cdd du
monde etc
s'il n'y a pas d'emploi il n'y a pas
d'emploi et est actuellement vu le
nombre de chômeurs non on n'a pas de
travail alors fourni dans le contexte
actuel donc on aura beau les précédents
tous les sens ça fonctionnera pas mieux
on les aura juste pressé dans tous les
sens et à la limite on aura fait des
économies sur leur dos parce que vu
qu'actuellement
la pression fait que au moindre rendez
vous au point n'est pas comme demandeur
d'emploi vous une partie de vos
allocations c'est une souris aussi une
façon de payer moins d'avoir un système
de protection sociale moins onéreux mais
que ça fonctionne non actuellement ça
fonctionne pas et encore une fois le
risque le mérite et c'est ça
fonctionnerait si on était dans une
société pour le coup ou toutes ses
cartes étaient redistribuées en
permanence mais c'est pas le cas
le capitalisme c'est un système qui
reproduit
une structure à travers le temps les
postes de direction du capitalisme
l'époque de possession du capital c'est
pas des choses qui à chaque génération
seront distribués c'est faux c'est tout
l'inversé on est un système qui se
reproduit dans le temps entre les
générations au sein d'une même classe
sociale
c'est tout le principe des heures quand
on dit de classe sociale la classe
bourgeoise on dit beaucoup c'est une
classe pour soi une classe en soi casse
pour soit parce qu'elles existent
qu'elles sont absentes soit parce
qu'elles existent et classe pour soi
parce que c'est des gens qui ont
conscience de leur propre classe et qui
font tout pour perpétuer cette cette
classe là donc c'est des gens qui font
en sorte en quelque sorte que les places
soient toujours pris davance voyez la
place deux jours que je prends cet
exemple là parce que c'est quelque chose
qui est hyper répandue la place
d'alexandre mulliez petit neveu un petit
fils gérard mulliez
elle est prise c'est lui qui la prend
voyez c'est pas on vit pas dans un jeu
une sorte de jeu à chaque fois on se bat
tous à égalité pour obtenir des places
ça s'est un peu l'utopie mais c'est
intéressant c'est un peu d'utopie pour
le libéral ce serait de dire il faudrait
une société où il ya des très riches ou
des très pauvres parce que c'est bien
mais il faudrait que tout le monde
puisse aller de l'un à l'autre
uniquement en fonction de ses
caractéristiques personnelles
admettons c'est pourquoi pas mais
actuellement on est exactement dans le
show d'un verse ses fonctionne pas du
tout comme ça en fait et dès lors aux
états unis où on veut ne se révéla comme
je disais ça fonctionne pas du tout
comme ça vous employez donc invoquer
veux dire c'est que vous faites très
attention à la question du langage
puisque c'est sur quoi portait votre
votre ouvrage
et on peut observer dans dans votre
engage une une conscience d'une certaine
volonté de la classe dominante de
justement dominé et conserver sa
position qu'il rentrait une classe pour
soi qu'il y en a conscience qui veut
perpétuer cela est-ce que comment est ce
que vous vous justifier cette prise de
position est ce que vous pensez vraiment
que la classe dominante
une volonté d'exclure les personnes
défavorisées ou est ce que c'est juste
un comportement normal qu'on est quand
on a l'opportunité d'avoir un poste
d'accéder à ce poste sans avoir le
réflexe de de se dire qui va aller
travailler à leasing parce que peut-être
que quelqu'un a pu méritants pour
accéder à ce poste
bien sûr c'est une question très
importante que vous posez il y à il ya
deux pôles qui s'opposent sur cette
question je pense qu'il ya un pôle qui
est très longtemps en ce moment qui le
pôle conspirationnistes canton et
conspirationnistes par exemple on pense
qu'il ya un petit groupe qui prend des
décisions conscientes pourra servir le
reste de la population donc par exemple
avec une lecture conspirationnistes des
choses tout ce que je vous dis depuis le
début par exemple ça serait alors c'est
vrai que c'est une façon d'interpréter
mes propos il faut faire attention comme
on le dit ce serait de dire la
bourgeoisie c'est quasiment une classe
unifiée qui tient un conseil
d'administration chaque année et qui dit
voilà comme on va réussir à truster les
places
voilà la dernière méthode à agir et
c'est ça c'est la vision a construit un
suivi d'une qui donne une volonté forte
à un groupe volonté forte et structurée
en réalité et ça se passe pas comme ça
bon je vous prends pas et
scientifiquement d'ailleurs ça se passe
pas comme ça ce qui se passe plutôt s'il
ya des effets on qu'on pourrait appeler
structurel c'est à dire que quand on
regarde le fonctionnement sociologique
d'une classe sociale une classe sociale
et se définit par des intérêts communs
et ses intérêts communs ils peuvent être
conscient ou inconscient
c'est à dire que au sein de la même
classe ou on n'a même pas conscience de
faire partie de ça c'est important
c'est à dire que même au sein de la
classe bourgeoise alors moi je pense que
quand les travaux empiriques sur la
classe bourgeoise ont montré que c'était
un peu la classe sociale qui avait le
plus conscience d'elle-même
les bourgeois ont relativement
conscience de des bons joueurs mais
c'est pas le cas tout le monde et ça ne
passe pas par un grand conseil des
ministres assurent annuel par contre il
est vrai que c'est une case qui organise
et politiquement c'est à dire qu'elle a
des partis politiques qui la représente
elle a des lieux de sociabilité
[Musique]
cernés dans lequel elle gère ses propres
aux affaires indépendamment du bas de la
société
donc ces lieux de sociabilité ça peut
être des clubs
ça peut être des des associations ça
peut être des mêmes la franc maçonnerie
c'est parti de ces mécanismes là on
attribue tout un tas de trucs à la franc
maçonnerie pour la france maçonnerie
c'est un lieu de sociabilité parmi
d'autres ceux qui disent tout se joue là
c'est faux non en fait dans les classes
dominantes ya tout un tas de lieux
il ya aussi les dîners voyez le dîner du
siècle
c'est quelque chose qui fait aussi
beaucoup fantasmé c'est un lieu place de
la concorde à paris où chaque mois il ya
un dîner qui rassemble des membres de la
classe médiatique des politiques des
ministres des chefs d'entreprise ils se
retrouvent et discutent sur des sujets
tout ça est très bien organisée mais
c'est pas non plus là que tout se décide
c'est tous ces lieux là qui contribuent
à forger une politique de classe alors
qu'ils aient pas unifié ne sont plus
aussi un vecteur pour jaurès il ya des
forces qui s'affrontent et d'ailleurs on
le voit politiquement voyez il ya la
bourgeoisie de droite traditionnelle qui
va plutôt pousser ses candidats deux
doigts par exemple quelqu'un comme
françois fillon c'était vraiment le
candidat de la bourgeoisie
traditionnelle du patronat
traditionnelles ancestrales et puis
macron c'est autre chose c'est une autre
bourgeoisie qui est plus urbaine qui est
plus dans l'économie numérique un tous
les soutiens c'était ça que vous aviez
niel et c c'est à dire voilà d'autres
d'autres formes de capitalisme
et puis ils s'affrontent un peu pour
l'exercice du pouvoir alors faire donc
donc il ya en plus de 5,4 des intérêts
divergents mais si vous voulez quand je
dis c'est une classe qui reproduit ses
intérêts à travers le temps
c'est particulièrement le cas alors là
je ne me base entièrement sur les
travaux des sociologues monique et
michel pinçon charlot qui sont des
sociologues de la bourgeoisie qui ont
fait beaucoup d' enquêtes de terrain
notamment dans les grandes familles
bourgeoises et eux qu'ils regardent
fonctionnement de la structure de la fin
du monde et notamment on constate que
c'est des familles on contrôle beaucoup
même les fréquentations des enfants en
organisant par exemple des rallyes donc
des soirées privées pour souffert entre
les enfants qui rencontrent les bonnes
personnes qu'ils aient accès aux bons
réseaux qu'ils aillent dans les bonnes
écoles etc et donc tout ça mis
bout-à-bout coïncide à ce qu on
une classe qui est homogène dans le
temps qui se reproduit longtemps qui se
transmet ses richesses son réseau etc
mais ensuite qu'individuellement on a
affaire à des gens qui c'est la dernière
partie de votre question pour moi du
coup il faut pas mettre trop de morale
là dedans c'est à dire que les individus
qui a intérêt à agir dans ce système le
fonds pour de bonnes raisons ils ne font
pas pour des raisons de machiavélique
ils ne font pas pour le plaisir des
cartes et les autres souvent ils le font
on peut même dire ils le font par amour
on veut dire des parents qui cherchent à
faire en sorte que les dans leurs
enfants et toutes ses décors ma ça peut
être d'ailleurs à mon avis assez qu'ils
font je doute que les enfants de la
bourgeoisie soient les plus heureux
ailleurs vous voyez faut vraiment écarté
la question de près la question du
bonheur là c'est encore autre chose vous
n'est pas dans la sociaux mais voilà
après on peut on peut spéculer là dessus
mais il faut quand même écarté la
question morale quand on parle des
classes sociales parce que tout ça c'est
quand même des structures qui nous
dépasse largement largement et ensuite
pour la plupart des gens mais après il
faut bien voir que ces classes sociales
ont des représentants qui euh comment
dire agissent activement en faveur de la
classe qui représente donc par exemple
ça peut passer par la politique
quelqu'un comme je prends l'exemple de
françois fillon n'en parle plus beaucoup
de chefs de cette personne mais qui pour
moi était vraiment symboliser le
candidat de la plate bourgeoise comme on
a vu depuis des décennies ouais c'est
quelqu'un par exemple il avait dit
explicitement que il voulait il ne
pouvait pas mettre fin à la sécurité
sociale mais parmi ces trucs avec l'idée
de de réduire considérablement la
sécurité sociale voilà on voit bien
qu'on a une revendication de classe
parce que la sécurité sociale c'est
quelque chose qu'on va être beaucoup le
patronat puisque la sécurité sociale est
financé en partie sur les cotisations
des employeurs
c'est quelque chose qui bénéficie d'un
don dont la classe bourgeoise pourrait
se passer parce qu'elle a déjà
suffisamment d'argent pour payer ses
propres soins etc
c'est le cas aux états unis par non et
c'est quelque chose qui bénéficie
surtout à la classe laborieuse et qui a
été mis en place à la libération par les
communistes et la cgt c'est à dire ses
représentants
travailler en a clairement un objet qui
est très clivant socialement et donc oui
là c'est la partie un peu plus actif du
travail des classes sociales
c'est de se faire représenter
politiquement et les représentants de
cette classe sociale vont vouloir
tendanciellement faire des choses en
faveur de cette classe là quand mac
qu'on supprime l'impôt de solidarité sur
la fortune
là pour moi on est vraiment dans une
politique de classe et ça a été quasi
assumer c'est à dire l'idée c'était de
donner les mains libres aux
investisseurs va pas dire niveau vers
les investisseurs puisqu'il est présente
en tant qu'investisseur pour leur
permettre d'investir plus ce qu'ils
étaient un raisonnement faux puisque en
fait le principe de l' isf c'était
justement d'empêcher l'argent de dormir
et de faire en sorte qu'on investisse
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que pour
moi on est clairement là dans une mesure
de classe sous couvert de fonctionnement
macroéconomique on a clairement quelque
chose qui a bénéficié à énormément de
gens situés au sommet de la population
donc comment il faut bien les réaliser
alors même qu'il a été remplacé avec
simplement supprimé il a été remplacé
sur la partie de taxation de
l'immobilier oui mais il a été supprimé
sur la partie du patrimoine mobilier
c'est-à-dire financiers sinon oui
effectivement ça a été remplacé par les
filles mais la partie financière a été a
été a été sublime vous parlez vous
preniez l'exemple tout c'est l'heure des
des rallyes vous avez vous parlé de la
famille mulliez le pilier des états unis
vous parlez beaucoup de la reproduction
des élites et dans votre livre vous
rappeler qu' il ya des vents portants
député ouvriers en 1945 à l'assemblée
nationale qu'il n'y en a qu'il y en a
zéro aujourd'hui et vous dites également
que emmanuel macron en arrivant ou
quelques sont en quelque sorte confirmé
cette reproduction des élites puisque il
a voulu renouveler l'assemblée nationale
mais que le nouveau personnel qui est
arrivé c'était des appartenait la même
classe sociale puisque c'étaient des
avocats des cadres hectares et donc ça
reste et de la bourgeoisie donc
finalement il a il a changé les têtes
sans changer sans changer la danse
sociale et me permet de rebondir sur une
question que vous abordez également
brièvement dangereux suivre puisque vous
parlez des clivages
il ya au sein du peuple notamment les
clivages la france est immigré qui passe
gold droite clivage
progressistes-conservateurs etc et est
ce que
ce serait pas la promotion de ces
clivages au sein du peuple ne serait pas
une stratégie delà de la bourgeoisie de
en quelque sorte de diviser pour mieux
régner
quand on parle de stratégie il faut se
méfier
la question d'intentionnalité c'est à
dire qu'on a à faire encore une fois un
groupe social structuré un groupe qui si
vous voulez dont les membres sont aussi
influencés par des idéologies et si on
veut encore considérer les choses
normalement qui sont persuadés de faire
les choses bien et la question du bien
ou du mal là dedans on doit être très
souvent nation c'est qu'est ce qui se
produit en termes d'effets de structure
de classe
toujours est il que la libération après
la seconde guerre mondiale et un moment
de vendre grande distribution des cartes
politiques entre les différentes classes
sociales ça est déjà été plus ou moins
le cas au moment du front populaire
quelques années plus tôt mais ça a été
une expérience très courte mais toujours
est il que à la libération ce qui se
passe c'est que la bourgeoisie et dans
un sens mis beaucoup hors jeu en france
à la bourgeoisie économie qui a régné
sur le pays
auparavant déjà parce que beaucoup
d'entreprises sont nationalisées en
répression en réaction à la
collaboration avec l'occupant nazi
donc déjà d' équilibre des forces
sur le plan économique est complètement
revu et puis parce que donc la
libération c'est très important pourquoi
20 % d'ouvriers à l'assemblée nationale
parce que tout simplement on avait un
parti communiste très fort qui à
l'époque pour le coup je parlais de la
gauche du temps elle représentait une
classe sociale le parti communiste de
l'après guerre
ce voeu représentants des travailleurs
et donc mais un en-avant et fait monter
en son sein des ouvriers et des employés
d'où le fait qu'ils soient très
représentés à l'assemblée nationale ça
c'est la situation en 45 et donc c'est
le moment de notre histoire où
politiquement léché institutions ont été
les mieux répartie entre les classes
sociales et donc ça change beaucoup de
choses parce que du coup la politique
elle a été faite en fonction d'intérêts
divergents
certes puisque la bourgeoisie a pas été
rayée de la carte ce n'est pas une
révolution mais c'est un rééquilibrage
du coup la mise en place de tout un tas
de systèmes bien plus favorable à la
classe laborieuse qu'à la bourgeoisie la
sécurité sociale en est un exemple mais
la nationalisation de l'énergie
la nationalisation de nombreuses
industries en est un autre
parce que quand vous nationalisez par
définition vous vous faites en sorte
qu'ils aient plus de profit privé qui
soit possible donc vous couper les
vivres de la place possédantes ça c'est
sûr donc il ya eu ce grand équilibrage
et puis je dirais que depuis on décline
mais à nouveau dans des mécanismes
monopolisation et finalement c'est vrai
que symboliquement c'est important vous
en parliez le moment où emmanuel macron
excès de pouvoir et où sa nouvelle
majorité accéder au pouvoir
et là on a plus d'ouvriers à l'assemblée
nationale ça veut dire qu'en réalité
si vous regardez sociologiquement que
pourra et largement monopolisé par la
classe bourgeoise et son bourgeois c'est
à dire ceux qui possèdent et ceux qui
ceux qui bénéficient de l'ordre établi
donc encore une fois il est petit en
bénéficient qu'ils veuillent ou non à la
question n'est pas moral c'est pas des
gens qui sont là pour ça mais il se
trouve que il ya toute une série de
professions que vous occupez donc ils
font que vous bénéficiez du système tel
qu'il est en tout cas il ne vous ne nuit
pas donc soit enfin et l'ironie du sort
je dirais vous avez raison c'est qu'à
l'époque s'était présenté comme un
renouveau
c'est à dire une nouvelle majorité à
l'ère où m elle a été présentée comme un
renouveau du personnel politique est
d'ailleurs beaucoup de gens l'ont
interprété comme ça mais en réalité si
vous regardiez sociologiquement ce
n'était pas un renouveau c'est un
approfondissement
c'est un approfondissement de toute la
logique qui avait eu lieu dans les
décennies précédentes et qui aboutit à
donc à l'effacement des ouvriers des
employés du corps législatif et
politique en général et donc là quand on
voit ça va forcément c'est pas un hasard
que un an plus tard on est mouvement de
gilet jaune qui explose le nom vendée
gilet jaune qui se revendique vraiment
comme l'expression politique radicale de
ceux qui ne sont plus représentés
politiquement
quelque part c'est presque logique
sociologiquement que cet événement a eu
lieu
c'est vrai que ont fait constat dans
énormément de questions que la
représentation sociale reste toujours un
peu la même puisque alors que l'école
est gratuite obligatoire que
l'université gratuite que les étudiants
peuvent toucher des bourses des classes
préparatoires ne compte que 7 %
d'étudiants oublié et 11% deux enfants
employé vite de d'employés vous le
soulignez dans votre ouvrage d'ailleurs
une égalité des chances n'est pas
atteinte en france et selon un rapport
de l ocde la france affiche je cite
d'ensemble une mobilité relativement
faible par rapport aux autres pays
elle se classe ainsi avec l'allemagne au
rang des plus mauvais élèves européens
donc comment concrètement rapidement
faire redémarrer l'ascenseur social
alors il faut interroger cette question
est-ce que alors comme je le disais déjà
et ce qu'on veut un ascenseur social
c'est à dire est ce qu on veut un
système inégalitaire dans lequel chacun
puissent gravir les étages
première question déjà et ce qu'on veut
ça ou bien est ce qu'on veut une société
plus égalitaire
première chose est de répondre à chacune
de ces questions après sur mes propres
opinions parce que là on entre dans le
domaine de l'opinion des questions de
philosophie politique
deuxième chose est ce que c'est possible
vraiment d'avoir un système inégalitaire
où on puisse monter de base en eau est
ce que les gens est-ce que les dominants
le veulent vraiment ça c'est aussi la
question c'est à dire que si vous voulez
le prix à payer si on voulait un
ascenseur social
c'est pas allé quelques mesurettes qui
sont actuellement pour mettre 30 % de
boursiers à sciences po temps 2% de
bourse et la sas et c'est pas des c'est
pas des réformes structurelles ça c'est
juste des réformes cosmétiques et
d'ailleurs les résultats montrent que
après dix ans de dispositifs si égalité
des chances à sciences po paris
ben en fait la répartition sociale est
toujours la même mauvais que ça sert à
rien de faire les choses à la marge
et donc si on voulait vraiment un
ascenseur social et là c'est une réponse
sociologique
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire et bien
par exemple il faudrait faire en sorte
qu'on ait pu un système
d'éducation de vitesse le système
français s'est donc vous l'avez d'écrire
enfin à trois vitesses d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs on a un système à trois
doutait c'est à dire première vitesse
une voie professionnelle dans lequel si
vous allez oust déjà vous y allez très
jeune en apprentissage
on envoie les gens à 14 ans une fois que
vous êtes en apprentissage puis en bts
etc
vous êtes coincés dans cette voie là ya
pas de pas de ponts donc ça c'est la
première voie on va dire pour la forme
et qui est monopolisé par la portion on
va dire inférieure socialement de la
classe laborieuse première voie
professionnelle
ensuite il ya la voie générale mais
cette voie générale et elle-même 10
heures de voix première voie la voie des
iut et des universités on pourrait dire
la voix un peu moyenne en quelque sorte
qui est vous fait vous avez une
représentation ouvriers employés
professions intermédiaires un peu plus
forte
voilà qui vous amènera à des métiers
qualifiés mais subordonné
et puis vous avez cette troisième voie
qui est la voix classes préparatoires
aux grandes écoles qui est pas mal une
exception française d'ailleurs et qui
est une exception française parce qu'en
plus elle est publique c'est à dire
qu'il est financé par le contribuable et
cher parce que vous parliez de des
différents montants mais par exemple
auront ont dépensé deux fois plus pour
un un étudiant à en classe préparatoire
qu un étudiant à l'université ou en
apprentissage
les choix sont clairs actuellement les
choix sont clairs c'est de donner plus à
ceux qui ont beaucoup qu'on n'est pas
dans un choix ascenseur social
actuellement on est dans un choix
conforté ceux qui sont déjà bien et les
autres on les répartit donc si on
voulait si vraiment vous voulez un
ascenseur social
et moi j'ai pensé possible eh bien il
faudrait faire un seul et unique système
où à tout moment vous pouvez changer des
cheveux ou à tout moment vous pouvez
vous distribuer et à tout moment il est
possible d'atteindre des postes de
direction ne différencie tu vois
professionnels déjà en différence est
plus voie propre voie technique dite et
voit intellectuelle je pense que ça
c'est une première étape et moi
j'appellerai nerveux parce que je pense
que l'on doit beaucoup
les gens sont pas très heureux de sa
fille y compris ceux qui sont dans les
voies intellectuelle moi j'ai ensuite eu
pidement l'exemple moi j'ai fait
vraiment des études de philo de sociaux
etc et maintenant je me retrouve à faire
des travaux agricoles et pour moi c'est
très politique de faire ça c'est à dire
je me rends compte que si je veux être
cohérent avec moi
je peux pas simplement de contenter de
lire des livres et d'en écrire et met
d'ailleurs si j'écoute mes propres
besoins
à 30 ans passés j'ai aussi besoin de me
servir de mes mains et beaucoup de gens
ressentent ça c'est la fameuse creed des
trentenaires diplômés le nombre de
trentenaires diplômés qui décide de tout
plaquer pour aller monter une ferme
c'est même un rêve très répandue donc ça
veut dire ça veut bien dire qu'en plus
ce système me contente même à ceux qui
sont censés voilà et et moi moi j'ai
fait une voie moyenne l'université mais
je connais aussi des gens contre les
grandes écoles qui sont dans la même
perspective et à côté de ça on a des
gens qui ont été dans des voies très
professionnelle très technique dès leur
plus jeune âge et qui sont frustrés ne
pas pu avoir un call et des bas à la
voilà autant de lectures au temps de
l'écriture qui sont quand même des
privilèges aussi donc si vraiment on
veut la censure sociale faut faire péter
tout ça et c'est là qu'on revient à la
question des intérêts de classe d un
réseau c'est qu'en réalité vous voyez
que ben on est une classe dominante qui
est très conservatrice là dessus qu'ils
supportent pas qu'on touche à sciences
po paris qui supporte pas qu'on touche
aux classes préparatoires
la moindre petite réforme qui est qui
qui est engendrée qui est faite
là-dessus il ya tout de suite une levée
de boucliers je me souviens au début du
quinquennat françois hollande il ya eu
une tentative je crois de démocratiser
un peu exaspéré par un toit aux vérifie
juste plus exactement en quoi ça
consistait et tout de suite ça est
abandonnée il ya eu des pétitions de
tout le monde tout le monde a dit que
c'était une atteinte à l'excellence
française
vous voyez quand on dit il faut relancer
l'ascenseur social moi ce que je
constate tout le monde dit ça mais alors
ceux qui le veulent vraiment et encore
une fois je dis ça passerait par
fusionner ses différents systèmes
partager le partage du gâteau ne le
veulent pas donc voilà pour moi c'est
vraiment les deux questions qu'il faut
se poser quand on quand on dit la
censure sociale c'est est-ce que déjà on
veut vous souhaitez inégalitaire dans
l'absolu voilà mais admettons moi je
pense que fin moi je pense qu'on pourra
voir une société plus égalitaire avec
une hiérarchie des métiers qu'ils soient
moins grande ou les métiers les plus
pénibles soit pas les moins bien payés
ou et métiers les plus agréables soit
pas forcément les mieux payées fin voyez
on pourrait avoir déjà ça faut
s'autoriser à penser ça parce que si
simplement on se dit on veut juste
relancer l'ascenseur social
c'est une façon de se dire mais l'époux
il y aura toujours les éboueurs mal
payés qu'ils ont le dos
10 à 50 ans et il y aura toujours
envoyer des cadres très bien payé qui me
qui cumulent tous moi personnellement ça
me faut que devraient faire les choses
et puis ensuite deuxième question c'est
cet ascenseur social
on le relance mais à quel prix et est ce
que vraiment ceux qui en bénéficient
vont être d'accord moi ça je prends pas
l'autre l'entrevue avec va bientôt
toucher à sa fin on a juste une dernière
question vous posez dans son livre les
populismes les demeurés de l'histoire
chantal delsol avance une une thèse sur
la gauche qui depuis le prendre date de
mai 68 ne défendrait plus le petit
peuple au profit des deux qu'elle est ce
qu'elle appelle les nouveaux imprimés de
l'histoire donc qui sont sur des
critères de sexe de race de religion etc
il explique cela par le fait que après
mai 68 les élites se soit rendu compte
que se sont rendus compte que le peuple
était un des td des petits bourgeois
conservateur et qui n'adhérait plus à
l'idéal du progrès et on peut faire le
parallèle avec ce que vous même vous
dénoncez dans votre livre c'est à dire
là le fait qu'une certaine bourgeoisie
de gauche fait la promotion de la
diversité pour occulter les vraies
questions les inégalités sociales et
donc déjà qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cette thèse de chantal delsol et est ce
qu'on pourrait penser que la lutte des
classes finalement pourrait être plus
détendu maintenant par une certaine
droite extrême notamment au
rassemblement national avec le vote
ouvrier certains discours anti et
élitiste que par la gauche le
traditionnel à beaucoup de questions
important que j'ai essayé de répondre
également alors je pense que j'ai
commencé par la dernière parce que elle
est importante je pense qu'effectivement
tout le monde se rend bien compte
politique que les questions sociales ont
été abandonnés du 20 ans et que les gens
n'en peuvent plus du coût et donc la
question c'est pour beaucoup comment
capter sa électorale et donc du coup il
ya des organisations politiques qui vont
essayer de mettre sédiments sur la en
avant mais il y à mettre en avant comme
le fait l'extrême droite et il y à la
réalité programmatique et moi je vois
bien que
vincent léna national veut mettre ça en
avant mais sur ce qui est de son
programme politique
il faut voir que pendant faim depuis sa
création le front national ça toujours
été un parti qui par exemple veut pas du
tout remettre en cause les structures de
domination liées à l'économie
c'est vraiment un parti qui a d'ailleurs
très peu une discours dessus et qui
maintenant en a depuis peu mais très
timidement par exemple marine le pen s
engager pour la retraite à 60 ans mais
longtemps d'ailleurs sans trop dire
comment ni pourquoi
mais le fn c'est surtout un parti qui
veut tailler dans la dépense publique
qui sur le plan économique a toujours
les mêmes orientations
les partis de droite c'est à dire voilà
il faut pas faire de communistes c'est
un parti anti communiste donc je dirais
que il ya les apparences il ya le disco
et puis il ya les actes est clairement
un rassemblement national au pouvoir il
changerait rien à tout ce que j'ai
décrit jusqu'à présent c'est pas un
parti qui veut combattre les inégalités
sociales par contre symboliquement c'est
un parti qui se place du côté qui veut
se mettre en scène du côté de la classe
laborieuse quand bien même il est
composé lui aussi de membres de la
bourgeoisie faut faut regarder la
famille le pen c'est une famille riesch
en connaît tous les des photos de leur
manoir etc mais même les cadres du front
national sont issus de la bourgeoisie ou
la petite bourgeoisie n'a pas trop de
différence avec avec les autres en
partie et quand bien même ils ont une
posture qui est différente et est la
limite ah oui leur discours savez de
dire on défend les classes laborieuses
parce que nous on veut lors débarrasser
de l'immigration qui est la cause de
tous nos problèmes et la question c'est
est ce que l'immigration est vraiment la
cause de tout ce que j'ai des crises et
à présent vous aurez une idée de mon
avis là dessus
pas du tout l'immigration c'est un
phénomène par ailleurs mais c'est pas à
cause de l'immigration qu'on a une
société aussi inégalitaire
loin de là voire même il n'y a pas de
lien entre les deux donc ça c'est une
première chose sur le rassemblement
national ensuite ensuite vous m'avez dit
il y avait plusieurs questions
concernant la thèse de chantal delsol si
dans la ville à la gauche qui aura
gauche ah oui très important alors c'est
très important
alors est ce est attesté par exemple
dans le cadre du parti socialiste
oui il ya eu tout un discours des partis
socialistes notamment qui a été écrit
noir sur blanc dans une note du think
tank terra nova qui est un film tank
proche du ps maintenant proche de l
hérault m
en 2011 donc avant l'élection 2012
c'était des politologues proche du ps
qui disait en gros c'était et noir sur
blanc un bon les classes populaires sont
acquises aux idées racistes ou
conservatrices donc c'est mort donc il
faut se tourner vers d'autres catégories
alors bon c'était pas du million de
rigueur sociologique et les jeunes les
immigrés les personnes lgbt nous qu'ils
aient un grand fourre tout comme ça en
disant les autres alors déjà et donc
grâce à cette note
on a beaucoup mis à jour cette stratégie
là mais qu'à une stratégie complètement
inconséquente par ailleurs pour moi
cette stratégie elle montre juste que le
ps veut abandonner les catégories
populaires
mais ce qui était en fait déjà le cas
pour - fusée 80 à nouveau ce différence
par contre cette stratégie pour moi elle
est erroné parce qu'en réalité
comment dire il faut pas séparer les
deux et nous dans notre réflexion à
frustration magazines comme dans le
livre on ne sait parfois en réalité ce
qu'on dit clairement et c'est qu'un
sociologiquement les catégories 10 tours
enfin les catégories aux primés dont on
dit qu'elles seront remplacées la lutte
des classes sont les mêmes que les
catégories aux clés de la lutte des
classes et donc en fait si vous voulez
quand vous êtes un immigré en france
bien sûr vous pouvez être défendue au
nom de la lutte antiraciste
mais il se trouve que vous êtes aussi
victime de l'exploitation économique et
en leasing et sont venus en france pour
être les plus exploités des exploités et
c'est encore le cas
donc en fait si vous voulez quand vous
défendez dax allemand mieux ce sera en
fait vous défendez ses différentes
dimensions à l'intérieur vous défendez
aussi les femmes face au patriarcat
pour moi tout ça est compatible est en
fait pas effectivement il ya eu une
bouche bourgeois ce qu'a voulu séparer
tout ça parce que bon ça lui permettait
de continuer d'être de gauche sans être
contre le capitalisme
ça c'est clair et net je suis assez
d'accord avec ça mais du coup son combat
pour les minorités a été aussi très
intense et quant à dire que si vous
regardez actuellement dans l'échiquier
politique la gauche qui défend le mieux
les minorités entre guillemets c'est
aussi la gauche qui est qui défend le
mieux les classes populaires en général
qui va avoir le discours plus radical
su si vous voulez je pense que
d'ailleurs l'évolution actuelle du
mouvement anti féministe antiraciste et
du mouvement anti du mouvement féministe
va dans le sens d'une plus grande prise
en compte des questions sociales
moi j'ai l'impression que il ya eu sans
doute une époque pas peut-être ces vingt
dernières années où on s'est mis à
saucissonner les problèmes on a dit
voilà il ya le racisme d'un côté il ya
les problèmes économiques de l'autre et
tout ça n'a pas dire j'ai l'impression
qu'au contraire de plus en plus de gens
font dire ce qui fait que oui pendant
tout un temps la gauche a voulu
saucissonné tout ça mais ça s'est vu si
vous voulez ça c'est vu particulièrement
sous françois hollande
on s'oriente voyez c'est le président
qui met en place le mariage homosexuel
mais s'arrête là et l'a fait de façon
comment dire à tous les mouvements lgbt
diront que ça a été fait timidement pas
la fleur au fusil et que s'ils sont
arrêtés sur tout un tas de vos
modifications
mais admettons ça a été sa grosse marque
du gauche par contre il a mené une
politique de droite sur le reste et ça a
nourri cette thèse selon laquelle
finalement les deux questions s'opposer
mais attention voilà moi je pense qu'il
faut oui il y a des gens qui pour ne pas
tenir de discours sur la lutte des
classes voire pour défendre la
bourgeoisie ou instrumentalisées des
questions les autres aux pressions pour
se dédouaner
mais déjà ils n'ont pas fait jusqu'au
bout et surtout si on veut le faire de
façon conséquente quand on lutte contre
des formes de domination de la société
on est obligé de prendre en compte leurs
interactions entre elles ce qu'on
appelle l'intersexualité qui fait
vraiment le terme c'est devenu le terme
qui fait peur mais la sociologie a
toujours fait l'intersexualité en
réalité on ceci sonne jamais les
problèmes comme ça ils sont toujours
liés sont toujours liés et le fait
d'être une femme dans la société
capitaliste bas créer des liens en
particulier qu'il faut étudier il faut
prendre alors merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup et nicolas fera non c'est déjà
la fin de cette entrevue donc merci au
nom de scopeo pour le temps que vous
nous avez accordé
merci pour vos missions nous avons nous
avons abordé beaucoup de points 2-2
sociologique sur la lah sur la lutte des
classes la stratification sociale la
bourgeoisie créerait donc nous nous
invitons au tout nouveau nos auditeurs à
lire votre livre la guerre des mots
s'ils veulent
plus et donc merci encore et je laisse
la parole à dominique pour le mot de la
fin
votre livre est donc toujours en co
écrit avec khalip qui écrit intéressante
et très bien écrit très est donc tout à
fait captivant et agréable à lire et
donc d'un côté cette vodka sera publiée
sur notre chaîne youtube scopeo le
serveur politique et elle fait suite à
huit autres entre vie politique et ce
n'est que le début donc pouvez aussi
nous rejoindre surtout de réseaux
sociaux donc instagram twitter linkedin
et facebook
ce complot l'observatoire politique
toujours merci beaucoup à vous merci
pour votre temps c'était tout à fait
passionnant et on donne rendez vous à
nos auditeurs pour la prochaine rentrée
politique a dit merci